christine lambrecht ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko für deutschland
in europa herrscht krieg und wir haben
eine novizin im verteidigungsministerium
eine frau die die rangabzeichen nicht
kann deren erster öffentlicher auftritt
sozusagen in dem sie sich da beschwert
dass sie jetzt diese ganzen
rangabzeichen lernen müsste die sich im
haus abschottet sowohl von der
militärischen führung als auch von der
beamtenschaft die spd apparatschiks in
den bendler-block rein schleppt die
außenpolitisch eine sehr schlechte
performance macht die öffentlich blüht
was die waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
angeht und die auch sonst komplett
fachfremd ist in sachen bundeswehr kein
gespür hat für die truppe kein interesse
hat an der truppe und eine absolute
notlösung ist diese notlösung können wir
uns aber heute nicht mehr erlauben und
deswegen sage ich jetzt muss man die
chance nutzen wenn man zeitenwende ernst
meint muss frau lamprecht gehen und zwar
sofort na ja also ich bin weit davon
entfernt jetzt kopfnoten zu verteilen
aber wenn wir uns die historie angucken
wer in den letzten jahren in der tat das
verteidigungsministerium geleitet hat
dann ist doch vielleicht erstmal
wohltuend dass dort keine person sitzt
die das als eine art von
durchlauferhitzer für ein nächstes
politisches amt nimmt das war mit der
cdu-vorsitzenden davor so dass wir mit
frau von der leyen davor so und wenn wir
unsere kraft naja wenn ich wusste dass
rom com ist sich
damals ja alle dass frau von der leyen
andere quasi karriereschritte geplant
hat das ist dann vielleicht eher an frau
merkel gescheitert das heißt vom prinzip
ist es jetzt so mit frau lamprecht dass
dort eine politikerin die sehr viel
erfahrung hat in verantwortung ist es
sicherlich nicht alles optimal in den
ersten monaten gelaufen aber wenn wir
uns die aufgaben die vor uns liegen in
der bundeswehr angucken was die
beschaffung angucken all das was in den
letzten 10 12 16 jahren versäumt wurde
dann ist es vielleicht ganz gut dass
dort eine politikerin sitzt die
eigentlich nicht mehr rücksicht nehmen
muss auf irgendjemanden und deswegen
glaube ich dass frau lamprecht das thema
lügen würde ich so nicht stehen lassen
dass frau lamprecht durchaus als das ist
aber lange rechteck von mir haben sie
aber es gibt auch der botschafter sagt
das eine ist auf der anderen seite auch
so dass der botschafter auch das eine
oder andere über mein parteivorsitzende
gesagt hat
wo ich sage da sind wir auch in der
aufgeregten situation aber stand auch
schon bei der frage wie lenski glaube
ich ganz gut ausgefüllt hat deswegen
muss man da ein bisschen die kirche im
dorf lassen es ist da nicht alles gut
gelaufen aber es ist gut wenn dort jetzt
eine verteidigungsministerin sitzt die
in der lage ist gegebenenfalls auch
widerstände die in der obersten führung
in der bundeswehr da sind weil es geht
ja nicht nur um mehr geld was wir für
die bundeswehr bereitstellen müssen
sondern auch die ganze beschaffung alles
andere ist desolat in der bundeswehr und
dass da jemand aufräumen kann der keine
weiteren ambitionen hat das zunächst
erst mal eine gute nachricht gab das
geht nicht mehr in der opposition sind
sonst hätten sie glaube ich nicht so
freuen wie über vor lambrecht geredet
weil es da schon sehr niedrig angelegt
das niveau an mit dem sie vergleichen
frau kam kam bauer hat in der tat
zugegriffen beiden amt brauchte und bei
frau von der leyen war es auch
eine versetzung der kanzlerin zur
bewährung aber das kann ja eigentlich
der maßstabs ja und dann möchte ich aber
noch was dazu sagen annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat sich voll und ganz auf
die bundeswehr eingelassen ist der
empathisch auf die soldaten zu gegangen
ja wir können uns erinnern als aus
afghanistan aus kabul diente er
nicht das ist ich das ist ein großer
fehler und wer hat auch die union
bei fragen ist es wirklich richtig dass
wir wichtige ämter mit leuten besetzen
die nichts werden wollen also hier muss
man auch mal verteilt ist wollte glaube
ich kanzler wäre das ist auch geworden
und zweitens
was ist eigentlich erfahrung
also ich glaube dass das
verteidigungsministerium zu führen
scheint ja parteiübergreifend ein sehr
schwieriges haus zu sagen ja ein sehr
schwieriger ist es doch nicht so
schlecht wenn jemand schonmal
ministerium erfahrung hat und nicht als
neuling dahin kommen weil der generäle
hinschicken und zum
verteidigungsminister machen also die
frage ist wo kommt eigentlich dann dann
der als der aus ihrer sicht
idealtypische verteidigungsminister oder
ministerin her das ist weil das eine was
ich sagen es gibt verteidigungsexperten
parteien na ja aber die sind dann also
ehrlich gesagt ich habe ja mal wenn auch
nur landesministerium geführt das ist
schon eine ziemlich komplexe aufgabe ein
kleines haus zu führen ein so groß ist
wie das verteidigungsministerium würde
mich sehr warm anziehen bevor man mir so
eine aufgabe anhören können die
wehrdienst verweigert haben jetzt
langsam mehr und mehr durchwachsen ich
habe hier geleistet das problem kennen
würde auch die dienstgradabzeichen
kriegen können aber ich glaube dass das
entscheidend sind prädestiniert ja das
ist sie eben gar nicht dass ich jetzt
also auch ohne ohne falsche
bescheidenheit erstmal ein fragezeichen
ich glaube wir sollten wir sind in einem
in einer dringlichen außenpolitischen
lage ich finde wir sollten jetzt nicht
anfangen erstmal personal konsequenzen
dann muss ich wieder jemand neues
einarbeiten also ich finde diese an
freier möglichkeit in der wirtschaft ist
es so wenn drei leute hintereinander auf
derselben position nicht erfolgreich
sind dann gilt eine klare management
regel müssen wir über die positionen
nachdenken um die randbedingungen
nachdenken weil die eierlegende
wollmilchsau die alles kann
jung jetzt so viel besser der waren mann
und könnte also die also lange rede
kurzer sinn die lange reihe ist länger
ich weiß auch nicht ob man von der leyen
kramp karrenbauer und lambrecht auf die
man die als außer sich alle drei frauen
sind würde ich sagen fans bei der
ähnlichkeit ja ja ich würde sagen es
auch alle gleich beurteilen ist findet
es aber am ende des tages ist dass man
jetzt zuviel schulnoten ich finde von
lambrecht hat eine aufgabe man muss sich
ein mann dass sie das wahrnimmt ich habe
das mit den 5000 helm ehrlich gesagt das
was ich politisch überhaupt nicht
verstanden habe
dass auch die inhaltliche bewertung die
ich verstehe noch nicht ganz was sie
jetzt mit der geheimhaltung will dass
der gehalt der transport geheim sein
muss ist klar aber die frage wie viele
ich meine bild tv zeigt jeden tag waffen
aus allen möglichen ländern die da sind
dass das offensichtlich klappt die dahin
zu bringen scheint zu
stehen
ich bin ich bin oppositionspolitiker ich
muss nicht hinter regierungsmitglieder
entstehen aber ich bin ein bisschen ich
finde diese über
vorwürfe ich finde wir sollten jetzt
erst mal als land zusammenstehen das
heißt ja nicht dass wir nicht aufsicht
führen als parlament dass wir nicht
kritisieren dass er nicht ratschläge
geben aber immerhin gleichzeitig
zurücktreten nach 120 tagen gesagt in
richtung spd sagen darf wenn sie mit der
truppe reden wir hören sie überall der
letzte wirkliche verteidigungsminister
peter struck spd ja also die spd kann
auch den reifen ist auch sehr gut so
viele probleme die heiligung muss aber
vorher auch kein parteilos politiker
also soweit aber motorradfahrer das ist
auch schon ist wir müssen jetzt ein
motorradfahrer der die
zu dem eigentlichen zurück und das ist
ja das wort sicherheitsrisiko es ist ja
es ist ja eigentlich das was mich auf
bürgeln sehr alarmiert und sie sind
wirklich davon überzeugt ist vor allem
recht ein sicherheitsrisiko voreinander
ist ja also ich bitte sie überspitzt
formuliert aber ja natürlich
grundsätzlich nicht gesagt der punkt ist
doch der und also da möchte ich jetzt
mal ein paar punkte machen erster punkt
ist frau lambrecht hat am wochenende
gesagt abrüstungspolitik ist sozusagen
immer noch ihr ziel in europa ist krieg
wer heute noch von abrüstung spricht und
sich aus alten spd reflexen drohne
sozusagen atomare bewaffnung bei was die
zertifizierung der 35 und so angeht wer
sich da nicht von lösen kann der ist
nicht in der realität angekommen
zweiter punkt
wenn ich höre habe ich in der welt
gelesen glauben alexanders
aufgeschrieben dass am tag der invasion
der ukraine frau lamprecht sich hat die
fingernägel machen lassen in der woche
weil sie nicht blutrot vielleicht ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen ja und danach
in die galerie lafayette luxus morgen in
berlin für die es nicht kennen zum
shoppen geht hugo neue kostümchen dann
hat man den ernster lage glaube ich
nicht erkannt und wenn nicht da
sozusagen dann auch noch und ob diese
verzögerung die verschleppung bei den
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine mit
bekomme wenn man merkt herr scholz nimmt
dir erst kompetenzen weg dann gibt er
ihr vielleicht wieder welche unter
gleichen na ja da muss ich mich schon
sehr fragen und der generalinspekteur
der bundeswehr
oberster soldat in unserem land hat sich
sehr schlecht zu frau lampe ist übrigens
herr meier ihre ihre kollegin frau
strack zimmermann vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses heute in der
welt auch sie haben die qualifikation
ist und sie fragen der in der welt war
was aber weil ich für die unis ruhen
lassen darauf hat sich gebunden
sie hat den mut von olaf scholz naja
wenn der rückhalt von olaf scholz ein
befähigt 1 im verteidigungsministerium
zu führen da muss man sehr fragen wir
müssen aber jetzt nicht aus
interviewsituationen heraus
interpretationen vornehmen können doch
erstmal die sachlage ganz nüchtern
analysieren das größte sicherheitsrisiko
was diese koalition vorgefunden hat ist
die bundeswehr die über 16 jahre kaputt
gespart wurde ja die in der situation
ist er hat auch nicht die er in
beteiligungskapital
beantragen haben wir wurden immer geld
und wir hatten das eben auch schon
geklärt wir reden darüber dass die
gesamte beschaffung desolat ist da wurde
über kindergärten den kasernen
gesprochen da wurde darüber gesprochen
dass waffensysteme
straßenverkehrs tauglich sein müssen
alle
sondersituationen sonderkonditionen die
beschaffung wahnsinnig verteuert haben
so das heißt also als erstes mal müssen
sie feststellen das sicherheitsrisiko
was sie momentan haben weswegen wir
vielleicht auch nicht die waffen die wir
uns gerne wünschen in der menge in die
ukraine liefern können liegt darin dass
die depots einfach leer sind ja das ist
eine bilanz von 16 jahren gerade
rechtsverteidiger niemandes geführte
regierung in so das thema drohne was sie
eben angesprochen ja wir haben in der
letzten
sitzungswoche als ampel die bewaffnete
drohnen beschlossen ja das hat die cdu
nie geschafft an welchen gründen auch
immer ist gescheitert auch das
festhalten
am tag der leyen gras des angriffs auf
die ukraine gemacht hat das finde ich
jetzt ein bisschen billig ich glaube da
müssen wir auf der ebene müssen wir
nicht hier miteinander das amt und was
die ware und jeder kann das die
waffenlieferungen angeht auch dazu
vielleicht noch einen punkt bevor wir
jetzt über schwere waffensysteme reden
wir müssen doch zunächst erst mal alle
festhalten dass glücklicherweise die
waffen die in der ersten phase des
krieges geliefert wurden genau richtig
waren wir reden über panzerbrechende
waffen wir reden über flugabwehr das war
genau die unterstützung die deutschland
aber auch andere länder geleistet haben
und diesen angriff vor kiel verneinen
wehrmacht moment müssen erst mal
festhalten bisher war es richtig und
jetzt reden wir jetzt reden sie hat
dirigent richtig verheißen regen auf
jetzt lesen hält darüber dass wie ich
noch keinen einzigen ich bin
haushaltspolitiker kein kein
verteidigungspolitiker wir reden über
ein szenario in der ost ukraine dass in
den nächsten zwei drei vier wochen hier
eine entscheidende schlacht geschlagen
wird sagen die experten unabhängig davon
wie lange der krieg noch dauert das
heißt wir müssten doch eigentlich jetzt
darüber diskutieren welche waffensysteme
jetzt kurzfristig hier weiter
unterstützung geben können und da habe
ich von noch niemanden gehört dass wir
innerhalb von drei vier wochen schwere
waffensysteme in die ukraine liefern
können unabhängig davon ob für einen
ringtausch machen ob der alte nva sowjet
bestände in die ukraine liefern dafür
westliches gerät dann in die nato
partner starten und darüber müssen wir
reden da müssen wir uns ehrlich machen
was hilft der ukraine jetzt im nächsten
wochen und ich glauben soll darüber
können wir zunächst erst mal diskutieren
dass wir mittelfristig darüber
diskutieren müssen was wir eine weitere
unterstützung geben können und zwar
zusammen mit unseren partnern auch das
hat olaf scholz gesagt